It was my birthday!
Hello everybody!
Hi!
Hello, hello, hello.
Oh, my voice is so dead today, I'm so sorry.
Actually, thank you for the gifted!
Thank you so much, you guys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday, thank you!
Thank you!
The concert was so amazing!
Oh gosh!
How was yesterday?
It was!
Oh my gosh, expertly produced.
Yeah!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
you can hear my voice is kind of yeah that's okay we're today is a little i have nothing planned um because i have nothing planned i was like well all i think about was the was the concert and now today i'm brain dead so i apologize uh we're just hanging out a little bit but thank you guys lots of people have commented and and I feel like I can't hear myself so many people have commented and so many people watched and I was really I was really nervous about it but I feel very happy I've been I feel so happy about it,
I was really, I was like, oh gosh, what if nobody watches?
And then I got the invoice yet, or I got the invoice before, before, um, I, before like the stream.
And I was like, I was like, what if nobody watches?
big number oh but i was really really happy so thank you guys so much
uh koi
thank you killed coin no yoku shiroku thank you party yesterday was so peak i got to hang out with all my friends
I can do something.
I like it again.
That was so much fun.
Happy birthday.
Thank you guys.
Thank you guys so much.
Best part was the bouncy skirt.
I know where you were looking.
Thank you.
Amazing.
Thank you for all you do.
No, thank you guys.
Thank you guys.
Spookiest B-day.
Thank you.
Yeah, I never thought I would be able to do something.
I mean, well, to be fair, I was going to say I never thought I'd be able to do something on that level as, like, an indie.
And to be fair, the project got started when I...
Because of Yishojo.
So, it's not that I did it completely as an indie.
But, you know, also, like, I guess also, how do you say, like, sometimes, not always, not always is the case.
I don't want to speak for every company, but some companies, they cover those types of events, you know, they either have their own studios or they'll, you know, if it's like a special event like that, they will cover the cost.
So for me, I was just like, the cost would always be so insane that I would never be able to do it myself.
But, you know, because of all of your, you know, your generosity and everything, of course I, of course I would want to go with something really high quality to give back, you know, so.
Because they even gave me a cheaper option.
They were like, it would be much less expensive.
It wouldn't look as nice.
And I was like, no.
I want it to look the best it could look.
Holy mama, did you deliver?
I really wanted to go as much all out as I could.
Original song was so cool.
Thank you.
I'm glad you liked it.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
You'll have to wait a little longer for the music video that I definitely have started.
Actually, I've had the song since like the beginning of this year.
But when I recorded it, originally, it was when my voice was just starting to get bad.
I actually asked if I could re-record it.
So I was like, I was like, I know that so much has been done.
I know that the song, you mixed the song and it's finished now, but my voice was so bad.
Please.
Oh gosh, right now my voice is bad though.
Right now my voice is bad, so don't think about it, but...
yeah been jamming all day thank you thank you thank you thank you so so i said i was just like please if there's any way yeah post a clip of your ori song from the concert so we can loop it maybe but but i would rather wait until like the actual music video,
no?
We'll see, we'll see.
But yeah, I did, I mentioned it in the concert, but I did get to record at Toei Studios.
I also retweeted them on Twitter.
The studios that I worked with, they were so, so, so nice.
And yeah, it was really awesome.
um the studio itself was the biggest studio i've ever been in it was crazy thank you guys thank you so much for super chats thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you um still pretty new to vtubers idols oh thank you um it looked huge yeah i had stairs i had a runway it was Was it all motion?
Yes, of course that was me.
That was all me, baby.
You can even see...
I...
I was...
You can see, uh...
There's a part in...
in a cute vampire girl.
Where I'm doing the dance.
And...
I lose my balance.
I lose my balance that I let go like
You saw Don't say don't notice Say right now that it was flawless And that you didn't notice at all No no don't say you saw Say what I couldn't tell At all Oh why no it was It was you danced perfectly It was flawless Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I know, right?
Now you'll notice because I told you.
It was flawless and I did not notice at all.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Only saw perfection.
I also...
You might be wondering too why my original song was done with the mic.
It's because I didn't have time to...
Well, I thought about it.
Like, should I make my own choreo for the song or should I get somebody?
And I thought about it and I think I went to commission a dancer for original choreography for it.
So that's why there's a mic stand until I have a full choreography.
Thank you.
So sorry for my...
for my voice today.
I missed you guys past couple days, though.
I haven't been able to say hello, so...
Never once noticed any mistakes VTubers claim to make during performances after the fact.
I think you'll probably notice that one.
I think you'll probably notice it.
But I think it's usually because maybe a lot of VTubers Just not a...
Well, a lot of...
You know, they'll have, like, choreographed dances.
But if you don't know the dance moves, how would you know that the dance was wrong, right?
So...
Setup was so good.
More, like, personality came through, especially on the dancing, which was completely flawless.
Thank you!
I practiced so much.
Hmm.
I practiced all the dances.
The dance with Kiwawa.
Actually...
Thank you.
Thank you for never giving up, princess.
Power, thank you.
Holy moly, moly.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Goodness gracious.
Thank you so much.
The dance with Kiwawa was also like, we came up with it in like one day.
We were like, She was like, what are we going to do for our song?
And I was like, hmm.
And so, um, and so, she said that on her stream.
We, uh, there's actually, for the song, the song is from, not Bakemo.
It's from the Monogatari series.
Um, but they do a little dance in the, in the, in the, opening ending I think it's the opening I don't remember but they do it and so we just copied that and then we also came up with their own stuff for the rest of it yeah yeah yeah yeah so that was from monogatari Victoria and Phoebe were so good yeah yeah actually Vicky was able to uh come to the studio too so unfortunately Phoebe couldn't make it little ghost but Vicky Vicky and I were able to hang out and everything so I love Vicky oh I told you guys I told you guys a story about how we were supposed how I was supposed to go to a hololive concert and then my friend and I got the date wrong
I can't wait I can finally talk about her Finally
talk about Vicky Yeah Please everybody go follow Victoria Roman On Twitter
Yeah And I got to hang out with her Again Over when I was Gone this past couple of days So Yeah, I love Vicky Already following Thank you Thank you, thank you Yeah Because I think we'll Probably all be collabing And stuff Eventually, hopefully, you know Favorite part was when Doki told you to get on all fours I had a feeling a lot of people would like that part I had a feeling a lot of people would like that part Yeah,
I honestly I wanted to get more people To To perform with me And also like, you know I was really happy Ayami Mama could Could make it And I wanted to do a song With Henya But I um she still has issues singing after because she was so sick for so long you know with her covid so unfortunately not this time but hopefully in the future hopefully in the future we can do a song together yeah but hopefully also next time um i can have more people I...
I...
Uh...
I had to...
I had to get the list of people like quite a long time ago and I really...
I...
I wanted to ask Nimi but I was too shy at the time
so Hopefully I will ask NIMI next time too.
Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, thank you so much!
Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky.
Minky.
Mmm.
Yeah, I want NIMI to be the next one.
I focused him downward dog what even is that hold on let me google it right now she didn't explain anything down word dog I think she just wanted to say it because she's a freak oh I think she just wait I think she just wanted to say it because she's a she said get on your knees you're not on your knees at all
Why did she like that?
She didn't know either.
I know.
Oh my god.
Like when she has a 3D.
Well, she's done like 3D stuff already.
But that was like her birthday and everything.
Yeah.
Or not birthday.
wait it was her birthday no like a birthday live at ax yeah
it was her birthday that's right but i only song i didn't get to tell her to do like any poses love the first halloween set song yeah i wanted to do like halloween themes um and then i also i was kind of crazy i was like can we do three different stages.
Can we do...
Was that like...
So crazy to...
To switch locations?
And they were like...
We can probably do it.
Everything I would ask for, they were like, yeah, we could do it.
So I was really, really happy.
And, you know, I can also use them again in the future.
So we can't forget the stairs.
Yeah!
Do you guys like that?
I thought that was, you know, it's...
I feel like almost something you don't see very often in, like, VTuber concerts or people walking down stairs.
Why is that?
What is that?
Many Beethoven's Walking Downstairs.
I had to flex a little bit.
Honestly, the studio was so large because they also filmed some of the animations for Common Rider and stuff in it.
So it was very, very tall.
And in the future, if I ever want to fly, they can rig me up.
And they can fly me around the studio.
Oh yeah, I retweeted the studio And this morning and I was looking at their Twitter And right underneath Right underneath the post about being like We were in charge of the animation And motion and everything for Mint Phantom Right underneath was We were in charge for the motion and expressions for And I was like...
No,
why?
So cool.
Sorry, I work.
Oh, no.
How could they work?
Common Rider Minto.
Oh, so.
I worked with the big boys.
A ghost that can fly preposterous.
Yeah, beam me up.
Yeah, kind of crazy.
Kind of crazy.
I do have...
I do have merch that will be up.
I haven't decided a time yet.
I was looking at Toyzukun Labs credits afterwards and they did the facial capture for DMC Vita.
DMC 5?
What?
crazy it was fate yeah
but I thought a lot about the set list a lot of songs that I wanted to perform and things that also were kind of spooky like cute vampire girl I've always wanted to perform that like dance and everything so so
Even though I'm not a vampire, I'm a ghost, but it's still spooky.
I tried to think of a lot of stuff.
I had a lot of fun watching your 3D live yesterday.
Thank you!
If you see the video I had made for you.
Oh, the princess one?
I did.
Thank you for singing Iron Master!
Oh my god!
Nah.
Guy is very skilled with his feet.
How does he do that clapping with his feet like that?
It's so loud.
I can't even clap that loud with my hands.
Did you see the other one?
There's more than one?
Wait, there's...
There's more than one!
I'll be honest guys, I'm a little brain dead today, so...
I...
I've been kind of like just...
There's just been...
I...
Sorry, wait, what am I saying?
I... I have been...
Brain dead today.
Yes.
I kind of have not even really looked at Twitter so much.
But we can look.
We will look at the hashtag and stuff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Happy birthday, Minto.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I'm just...
Ah.
But...
I'm glad that everybody seemed to enjoy the concert.
I'm really, really happy.
Thank you to everybody that helped me work on it and everything.
Yeah.
Oh, let me say...
Oh, hold on.
I'm talking about the merch stuff.
It'll
be 19 again!
Feeling good!
Oh, oh, oh, yeah.
One second.
But yeah, everybody, I have to update some of the credits in the in the description but um yeah please you know uh big thanks to the whole team everybody who helped with the concert and everything and um i'm trying to think of any other stories to tell uh i do remember i oh gosh i remember going to the studio
like toy studios and it's actually quite far away from tokyo um and i was going and you so basically i had to take a train there and then from there you take a bus but i was like oh well it's like a i think it was like a 15 minute 20 minute yeah like a 20 15 20 minute car ride and i'm so bad at figuring out buses.
So I was just like, I'll just get a taxi from the station.
That will be best.
And I waited for a taxi.
There was a guy waiting in front of me for a taxi.
And I was waiting behind him.
And he was waiting.
And waiting.
And I was early.
I was like 45 minutes early.
So I'm waiting.
And waiting.
And then the guy leaves because no show up and I was like well surely surely one will show up for me and I wait and I wait and then I was like oh I don't think I don't think a taxi is coming and I And at that point, I asked about the bus, and I asked a policeman about the bus,
and he did not help me.
So I was like, I think I have to walk.
And so, in the sweltering heat of summer.
Uber, you can call Uber in Japan, but Uber has banned me.
I can't use Uber.
so i cannot call and then i try using like those go taxi apps but they don't accept my card for some reason i don't know i didn't do anything in uber i did not one day i was banned i didn't do anything i swear i swear i pinky swear i did not do anything to uber i think it was because
The last time I used it was, I think it was like Anime Expo.
Oh, many, many years ago.
Like, like five plus years ago.
And my hotel was pretty close.
But, like, not...
I'm not, I'm not gonna...
I'm not gonna...
I'm not gonna walk at, like, 2 a.m.
by myself in downtown LA.
So I would do Uber.
I would do Uber.
And then, and then it was, but it was like such a short distance.
I've heard that they don't like you if you do really short distances.
And so I did that so many times because I was going back and forth the whole weekend.
I think maybe that's why they banned me.
Oopsie.
That's the only thing I could think of because I was the last time.
unless also it was like my first time using an an app but or like a like the uber app it was my first time using an app ever I know it was my first time ever doing like the ride share thing and I got into the front seat of the guy's car and maybe she didn't like that make a new account it's with one are you guys serious for right now it's it is connected to your phone number i have one phone just make a new account idiot oh okay let me let me just sign up for another phone plan god
you don't sit in front well i know that now I know that now, the guy like, he was just like, I got in the front.
I got in the front and he was just like, uh, can you like, go back there?
So I, I was like, oh, yeah.
So, sorry.
That was my first time.
I don't want them to feel like they're chauffeuring me around, even though that's what they are doing.
But I want them to be like, oh yeah, it's different.
Uber friends, yeah.
Oh, wait, hold on.
Yes.
Thank you.
So I have goods that will go up in 25 minutes.
I showed this yesterday at the end of the At the end But let's go through them So hold on Let me go, hold on, oh wait Oh wait, there we go, okay The first thing The first thing Is a t-shirt Wait, hold on, I have a bigger picture Here we go Look at that,
you guys On the back is my New logo!
Look at that.
Look how cute it is!
I finally have a new logo.
And then the front.
I drew that.
You too can be part of the Ghost Hunt crew!
Yeah!
The material, the printing of it is going to be like kind of that puffy...
coffee paint kind of material so you can rub your body and feel it.
But yeah, I drew that and that's awesome, my handwriting.
So I kind of wanted to be like a, like a, like an official, like a, how do you say?
Like a, like a staff shirt, you know, kind of.
Something like, I've been into those like varsity style things recently and i was like well this isn't quite varsity style i change it up a little bit but yeah cruiser yeah like a uniform a uniform no yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so um crew yeah we but you know don't like you're hunting but you're getting haunted by me so i thought it was kind of cute.
I was like, don't think so much about the ghost hunt.
You're going ghost hunting for Minto.
And then I drew that.
I drew the picture.
Yeah.
I think it's pretty cute.
So I hope you like it.
Yeah.
I drew that.
And also kind of wanted it to be like not super in your face anime but also if you if you if i see you if if someone sees you wearing it and knows me they'll be like oh yes that's me phantom you know so yeah i because i asked before i was just like do you guys like what what's wrong with my mouth Do you guys like...
Or in your face or subtle, but I'm in your face girly, so...
But at the same time, I know not everybody is, so I felt this was a good middle ground for us, okay?
I felt this was a good middle ground.
That is not...
Like, like, oh, that's definitely an anime girl.
So, yeah.
Yeah.
Good.
You like it?
Thank you.
It's subtle but cute.
I felt like it's also a type that anybody could wear.
It's cute for girl and cute for boy.
Anybody.
Cute for anybody.
Anyone can wear.
Yes.
Yeah, it doesn't have my pant- my panties on the back, so...
It does not have my panties on the back, so...
Rejoice.
You can wear this in public.
Or you could wear it in public anyway.
Anyway, next.
Sandy!
Sandy of the logo.
For the...
The concert and then also me!
The picture the Ayami mama drew.
It is plastic.
That's what acrylic stands are, yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
Is it one to one?
Shut up!
Next is a blanket!
It's starting to get...
Okay, first of all, I did not write these descriptions.
I don't know who wrote these.
But I didn't have time to even read them before I showed them on stream.
But it's starting to get kind of chilly.
I was just like, well, this is a Halloween show, right?
So you can get a blanket.
And this one does not have...
It's a clean version.
It does not have the logo on it.
So you can see the full art and all its glory.
Fua, fua, mofu, mofu.
Which is very true.
It is fua, foa, mofu, mofu.
So, it is a lap blanket.
I have one of these of Ayami Mama, actually.
So, wait.
It's kind of funny because this is also Ayami Mama art.
And, um, but, but my cat really loves it.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Fluffy snuff.
You can...
I will keep you one!
Next.
Slippers!
It does say delay.
That's so funny.
You can get two, the slippers that I have on my very feet!
But...
Also, basically all of this merch was like...
Stuff that I wanted to put out.
with V-Shojo and but with the people I'm working with now they were like we could do it it will just be a bit longer if that's okay with you and I was like oh I guess so cuz I would what I don't really have another occasion to do it with so yes yes yes jiggle jiggle jiggle wiggle jiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle the most wiggly wiggly wiggly wiggly wiggly why Why is the ringing so crazy here?
So yeah, if you decide to get the...
The slippers, it will cause the order to be delayed a little bit.
I'm so sorry.
But...
Are they pre-worn?
They could be.
You want that?
Extra service?
I'll like wear them around the cafe.
Get them nice and sweaty.
Can you wear the slippers?
Stop it.
Why do you all have the same idea?
One...
I was gonna...
I was gonna joke, like, one special...
One special purchase will be pre-worn.
But I don't want to...
I don't even want to even joke about it because someone will take it seriously.
They'll be like...
It'll be like me!
Whee!
Next!
Da da da da!
A plushy!
So we have mini Minto and now we have Fumo style.
Plushy 40 centimeters.
One pair of pre-warred slipper please.
Okay, it's for you Marina, I will.
Yeah!
This is, this image is also a prototype image, so it might come looking a little differently than this.
Just letting you know.
Um, but yeah, you too.
Thank you!
You too can now get, um, a bigger binto plushie if you would want so.
Yes, yes, yes.
Next!
That's it.
So yeah, for these five items, we do also have, we have a bundle pack.
But hold on, before you get scared about the limited quantity, for the bundle pack only, it is a limited quantity.
But everything else, like if you get things individually and hold on I'm getting ahead of myself if you get everything if you get things individually it is made to order so yes only the bundle pack is is limited quantity but that's because the birthday bundle has a small little discount if you get everything and then also comes with a Signed,
exclusive.
Ooh, signed.
But if you're like, oh, well, I only just wanted the Fuma.
So basically how it was explained to me is, hold on, okay, I'm going to get this correct.
I'm going to get this right.
So.
I'm gonna double check.
Okay.
So, there
is a set...
Wait, okay.
Okay.
So there's going to be... The first orders that will be prioritized is the bundle.
So if you get the birthday, a bundle.
And I apologize in advance.
I realized that I picked such, like, kind of big things that that the bundle ends up being and ends up being a little expensive.
I'm sorry!
It's... I was just like, oh, wait.
Because, like, you know, it's all kind of, like, big stuff.
I'm sorry!
But, if you get the bundle, those are the orders that are prioritized first.
And then everything that is made that is after the bundle after the bundle those orders will be shipped out later
yes my brain my brain
yes I think it was like a December estimated Maybe, maybe, maybe January because of the slippers.
Oh!
I got told I explained it right.
Yippee!
For, let me also post the link.
The link for merch is here.
Order the B-Day.
Oh, and also...
The orders will be open.
for one month so until the end of October is when you will be able to order it so you don't have to feel like oh my gosh I can't get it today you can get it closer to the end of the month as well yes I asked for that as well okay but But I'll give you the link,
but it will not be, the items will not be up until 10 minutes from now.
But the bundles are limited.
Yes, the bundles are limited, but there's a lot.
There's a lot, you guys, so.
And like I said, I'm sorry, it's quite expensive.
But all the items are...
There's many items, so...
And there's all very big.
I'm sorry.
bundle i will include some smaller items too so i apologize already i apologize already okay order the birthday merch here exclamation boy exclamation boy i'm still kind of new new to designing to creating my own merch lot let me you know so it somehow ended up becoming so many and also also i they were they were supposed to be like You know,
some things were supposed to be released earlier and then it was supposed to be the rest of the stuff for the concert or for my birthday and it all just kind of ended up becoming one big thing and I'm sorry!
Okay, I'm done.
Okay, uh, hold on.
I'm getting the link ready.
Wait.
Oh, there we go.
Pin So I'm actually working with Setsuna For this, so thank you Setsuna Production For helping me with this Or, uh, drop You might recognize them Because they've sold Ayami Mama things before So, yeah, yeah, yeah Yeah, yeah
No products found.
Yeah, I told you.
I, you guys, I told you it won't be up for another 10 minutes.
Get that earwax out of your ears.
Get your, get the earwax out of your ears.
I said so.
We don't listen.
Clearly.
It will drop at the top of the earwax.
hour it will drop at the top of the hour hmm stickers soon that'll be fun I guess the last time I did stickers was the podcast so it would be fun to do some more is there a t-shirt size chart let me see if they gave me one I
Wait.
Oh, the description that I was given says, See last image for size information.
So.
Um.
It should.
Once it's up.
Yeah.
I feel like it might be US sizing.
Honestly, I don't know.
Yeah, because I'm not sure where it's printed.
Sorry, guys.
I'm the worst person for you to ask.
It's not sold out.
You guys don't even joke about that.
You're going to make people think that it's sold out.
It's not up, please.
I don't want people to be like, oh, it's sold out.
I better not check again.
No!
Also, it doesn't sell out.
It's literally up for the whole month.
He'll get what you want!
Reduce the atoms.
Except for the bundle.
Well, the bundle is, you know, here let me add that to the little merch slide thing I got going on.
Bundle!
There we go.
E-ha!
Boom!
So I got
my bundle pack No, you didn't
Sold out last night No
Imagine the slippers will be like a Don't worry I'm sure they are Prioritizing the feet of the larger size So...
But it's those kinds of slippers, like the ones...
Like those kinds...
Like even my feet could wear them because they're like, you know...
They're just kind of like a slipping, you know?
So if you have smaller feet...
It also will work.
I bought 30!
No!
No you didn't!
Don't lie!
Stairs in size 5?
Me too!
I'm also size 5.
So don't worry.
Hold on, I'm gonna get cuff drop.
Let's see, where is my cuff drop?
Wait, do I have any left?
Sorry.
Oh, this one will do.
I'm size 43.
Can you find...
How?
Wait, size 40?
Wait.
Is that centimeter or so?
43 in EU.
Okay, that's EU size.
Can you imagine?
Thank you so much.
You know what they say?
i don't know what they say saying saying that you're like a size 43 in the us is like saying is like when when guys say that they're six foot yeah i'm six foot i'm six foot one yeah
12 and freedom mutants i don't even actually know actually now that i think about it i don't sizes at all because all I care about is my own.
Wait a second.
I don't even know.
Because there's also different sizes for men and women, right?
So like, if you were to say I'm a men size 7, I'd be like, is that big?
Like, is that a...
Be like, oh yeah, that sounds big.
Do you also buy your shoes in the kids section?
Yeah, because it's cheaper.
Men's size 7 is small.
Oh, my bud.
Really love to welcome the Mint Cafe.
Men's 7 is like a women's 9.
Why don't they just all make it one size?
Like...
Well, I guess they maybe wouldn't make size is my size in quote-unquote men's shoes.
Why do they have to segregate it, though?
Why do they have to make it different so that it makes me confusing?
Why do I have to be like a men's seven is a woman's nine?
That's so confusing.
It's one size in Europe.
Oh, my gosh.
America's always got to be different.
America's got to have.
America's got to have our individuality.
reality so confusing I'm
size freedom wait so if I'm size 5 what am I in the EU and then also what's funny is I don't know my size in Japan either because so many shoes places that I buy my shoes are like small medium large so I don't even know what I have in Japan either I'm like
EU shoe size Give me a chart, baby Okay, here we go Wait, what the...
Oh, this is men's shoes Okay, I was like This is...
Why does it start at 10?
Okay, women's shoe size conversion US 5 I'm like 4 and a half 5 You 4 and a half 5 UK is 2.5 Wait, Europe 36.
Thank you so much for being bored of my lines.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, one minute.
Until, oh, actually it's like 10 seconds.
Six, five, four, three, two, one.
I think the merch is up now.
Let's refresh.
Oh.
Refresh.
Ah, it's going up.
Street Team labs.
Thank you.
It's not sold out.
I clicked on him.
You're crazy.
Link don't go.
Link pinned.
Pinned.
They're all posted again.
There you go.
There's many, many.
You guys are fine.
There's no rush.
Don't worry.
Sample, design not final.
On everything.
Oh, ordering.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you,
thank you, thank you.
No, the slippers are not...
No, only the signed exclusive is part of the bundle.
Everything else individual is...
Is there too, so...
No worries.
Oh, they are US-sized.
The shirts.
I'm being told information literally as it drops.
If you get the bundle, please do not super chat me.
The bundle was so much money, please.
Please don't super chat.
Well,
yeah, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Perch drop!
Hippie!
Oh, I can't wait to see everybody get their stuff.
Oh, stop!
Stop it, stop it, stop it, stop!
I can't turn all super chats in, though.
I tried to quote Asala and Google A my super chat.
No!
Which idea for the future?
What about some freak phantom sunglasses?
I have thought about that.
I have.
Stop.
Stop it.
Stop it right now.
You guys...
We all got the bundle.
Stop!
Oh my god.
You guys...
Oh my god, please!
Okay!
Okay, the joke is over.
The joke is over.
Okay, okay, the joke is over, please.
Please!
okay we're done we're done we're done anyway thank you everybody for for for the merch thank you thank you thank you
i hope i hope when it comes in you are all very excited and And...
Um...
Yes!
Oh, look forward to it.
Oh!
I don't know what else to talk about, honestly.
I...
Oh, you know, as a ghost, it's hard to feel older.
I'm 19 again!
So...
When...
Yesterday was so much fun.
Have you read the description on the slippers?
Uh, no?
Freight.
Yeah, it's based on my Minto Taku outfit.
Yes.
Congrats on another 19th birthday.
Thank you.
Freight.
Read the plush description.
What are they writing here?
Smug, super deformed, possibly evil!
It might be, actually.
It's like Tiny Minto.
It's pretty evil.
Tis light in the evening.
What is this?
Possibly.
there are haunted dolls and all you might like wake up one morning and she's she's she's sitting next to your bed it's way too late to stop no one stops ha thank you so so so much thank you thank
you thank you just talking about haunted dolls.
Wait, was she really?
I'm so in sync with my Oshi.
So in sync with my Oshi.
Curse the Minky doll.
Wow, she might become cursed.
Oh, she is cursed.
She might become haunted.
She is haunted.
So how exciting.
You just got...
If you...
If you ordered the doll, the plushie, you have a new roommate.
Lucky you She won't pay rent And she won't contribute to groceries And she will make a mess
The worst roommate you could possibly ask for And you willingly let her into your home Congratulations
Happy birthday, Vido!
Thank you!
But she's cute.
Who is that princess guy?
I actually don't know.
I actually don't know who that is.
Is he just like famous for saying princess?
Got your bundle ordered.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
He's just the princess guy.
Who is he?
I already have a cat who doesn't pay rent and makes a mess.
Me too!
Can you react to him for us, please?
Let me pull up the hashtag.
Oh my goodness, thank you guys I'm seeing you guys posting about your orders even Thank you Thank you, thank you, thank you
Oh my gosh This cough drop is spicy
I really like the The clip of me going You're pretty good from my original song Yeah, I like that one.
I like it.
Yeah, I don't remember what kind this is.
I think it has ginger.
Thanks for the bundle, Vito.
Thank you.
Let me see.
I'm going through the tag.
Thank you guys so much for all the art.
It's so cute and all the posts.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
No.
Um...
Whoa!
Wait, I don't see this.
Wait, hold on.
I'm gonna...
Give me one second.
Let me pull up.
Wait, wrong thing.
Window capture.
Here we go.
Let me pull up.
I'm... Pull up?
I'm gonna have two more to work with.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, here we go.
Wait.
There we go.
Oh, gosh.
I don't know if I can react to this because I might actually pass away.
Wait.
Wait, also let me move this.
Hold on.
I have to rearrange some things.
I'm rearranging, get me...
One moment, please.
Ta-da!
What is this?
Oh!
No, I can't watch this.
I bookmark it?
Because I want to watch it later though.
But I can't watch this.
I think I will actually die.
Watch it?
I can't watch this.
Hello, Mint.
Plain name.
But I won't forget it.
What do you say to one last birthday showdown?
Acelots are proud creatures.
They never let their prey escape.
Ah!
Huh.
You're pretty good.
Until we meet again, John.
I mean, Snake.
I mean, mint.
Hello, mint.
Plain name.
But I won't forget it.
What do you say to one last birthday show?
Does
Josh get in the have a cameo?
Hello, mint.
Thank you.
making making
how is josh keaton good lord this bed is so handsome thank you so much thank you thank you thank you i think the donnas are very backed up but thank you thank you also I don't know how...
I don't know how a hot dog slipped into the console yesterday.
I don't know how that happened!
I don't know at all.
I don't know how that happened.
It was there and I heard it and was like, huh?
I'm so sorry.
I don't know how that happened.
I'm trying to find the princess.
Look how cute!
That's me!
Woo!
Before I read the Woo-Yam Baby, I was like, Oh, let me turn the music back on.
What?
This is awesome!
The cake!
And it's a box!
And I'm on there with Little Snake!
Was it yummy?
Yo, there's a slice here.
Was it tasty?
I love all the screen caps you guys will get the bus screen caps from the from the concert look they all look so are they make me look so cute
what is this why all these edited faces
they're making you make me look so
cute no this is a great one this is a great one
This is image.
Oh, it's such a cute setup.
Thank you.
Wait, I've never seen this plushie before.
This is so cute.
I'm glad everybody liked Kiara thumbs up in me while I tried to
keep...
Kiwa hanging out with Kiwa was always so fun.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
I'll get another Mickey Beauty Bundle.
Hey.
Hey, don't screenshot that.
Don't screenshot this.
And...
And post it!
Don't do that!
Mimi tear up watching you shy on the stage.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you!
Oh, so pretty!
I will go through and like things later, you know.
More properly, I want to go through and...
I was getting a Kiwawa behind me.
This.
I see the car crash and I immediately know what comes following.
Doki gave us what we wanted.
one another one also yeah i know that oh my god sorry it's so spicy um the this is the baki pose i know it now also what the hell what why would she do this to me this is the pose that i was supposed to do how could i do this i don't know but also oh my god Kaira!
Birthday party!
I saw some of you guys got together and watched the concert together.
You guys are so cute!
Sorry.
Ugh.
But thank you!
Yeah,
it's a really spicy cough drop!
It's the cough drops fault!
Not
crying because I'm so happy it's the cough drops fault!
It's so spicy!
Oh my gosh!
This one's funny.
She's such a sexy lady.
Oh yeah!
The background art.
A long, long time ago I asked for people who would...
Let me use their art for something.
It was this!
So thank you!
Thank you, thank you for letting me use your art.
Yes!
Oh,
so cute!
So cute.
Oh my god!
No!
What is with these edits?
On my face.
No?
This one I look so mysterious and spooky.
I really like this.
Wait, I really like this picture.
So, look at my...
Why are her hands like that?
I look so spooky and mysterious.
One thing.
Oh my gosh, wait.
The cough drop is actually trying to kill me again.
I spit it out.
Um.
One thing that was very cool with Toei that you will not find with like other studios.
This is the first time I've ever done this was I had like I felt like I was making a video game where I had like a whole rig on my head that recorded my face.
This is a little behind the scenes.
So...
Um...
Yeah, Kojima moment, real!
And... and I was...
So, so if you notice the facial expressions and everything, looking maybe...
Like, you know, if you maybe see my eyes dart around or something, everything is picking up everything which you know you don't find that many studios for concerts like this
so yeah it was very very cool technology did they scan your thighs
yeah I felt it felt very like the whole thing was like super duper professional But it was funny because it reminded me, there was also like a, there was also like a camera of my face, but it was like a GoPro looking camera on my face.
And have you ever seen those videos of like cats when they wear the cameras and they like, it's like very close up weird on their face and they're like running around and stuff?
That's what it looked like.
Yeah, like 0.5 POV.
Yeah, yeah.
There's like, there was just,
yeah, it's all nose of war.
Yeah, and it's from like, it was actually, honestly, pretty difficult dancing with it.
But every single, every single time you see, like, you know, everything here, I was wearing that big old thing on my head.
And recording took about I got there like 10 a.m.
About 12 hours of with it on my head.
11, 12 hours?
Oh yeah.
I was so, I was so sore.
Yeah, it was a lot going into it.
I think I did take it off for lunch.
But...
Uh...
I'm still letting you know we got that bundle.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
But again, like I said, I really wanted it to be as good as it could be, so...
I always push through that kind of stuff.
To...
In one session?
Yep.
Yep, yep, yep.
So...
You know.
And...
Um...
Even...
Even by the end...
I remember I was so...
Exhausted.
I was so, so tired.
But...
But as soon as like a music would start...
I would be like...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Like, I would like be dead.
And then the music would start and be like...
I would just want to run around and everything.
so yeah I did my best to have have as much of an exciting performance as possible
that's me oh wait this one's so cute too it's like I'm a princess oh yes I'm waving at my constituents
After I put it, it was very clear.
I can't, I mean, everybody says, like, you know, it looks so great.
But that, that, you know, I, that wasn't me.
So I can't take so much, I can't really take any of that credit.
Honestly, the production team, they busted their butts.
They made it look amazing.
And so, yeah, honestly, they did a great job.
great great amazing job so I said it I said it that daimanzoku like like so satisfied so so so feel felt so good cutie oh that looks so yummy yummy yummy yummy yummy yummy delicious as always.
Oh my gosh.
I really hope I can work with them again because they were just so great.
Yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy!
Yummy, yummy.
Kawaii!
Oh cute!
Cute, cute, cute.
Yummy.
Why are you guys always drawing me with or putting me with food?
What?
This is so pretty.
There's so much here.
Holy moly.
Love you, Minto.
Thank you!
Sorry, Camford.
No, don't apologize at all.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh, this is so cute!
Oh!
Ice Minky.
Oh, oh, everybody's here!
I stopped on the stumbling.
Thank you!
No way!
Wait a second!
Oh, wait.
Is this a cover?
Wait.
wait no way how did you cover this oh sorry i'm not gonna i don't feel like extending the camera or the thing so
it's a friday night what will you do oh my god i'm just a cat but i belong in a zoo you heard so loud i can hear it from the other room it's a cute is that colombo Give me a chance to make this all right.
I got the date wrong.
I should have checked it twice.
How did you know what the lyrics were?
See the twinkle in your eyes.
It'll lick on the nose for a surprise.
Don't tear me down or I'll be so gloved.
You can wrap my head or scratch my bum.
It's a Q-Doodle Saturday Whoops, suddenly it's Sunday I don't even know the words anymore I can't keep track anymore You know what they say Dogs can't read It's a Q-Doodle Next week day Next week day
Maybe we could try again next week.
That's so funny!
Oh my gosh, twinkle dogs!
So just send me all the royalties that you make from this cover.
That's so funny to make a cover of my cute cute cute cute cute little Friday night.
Oh my gosh, do you see a takedown?
Gosh, thank you.
That's so funny.
Borgger!
Yeah, Borgger, Borgger.
What a sick change she's got.
We need a cute music video.
I made it!
Actually, I can't...
So, the issue is...
The issue is, I can't upload it because I made it...
I did the music video during that stream in real time.
It was me pushing buttons.
So...
I can't...
I can't upload it.
Because I was doing it.
So, yeah, I can't...
I have no way to upload it.
I would have to, like, take it from the stream.
Cute.
Oh, so much stuff.
Thank you.
Oh, no.
My butt is out.
Never!
No.
The Nemo Tonagi Gosh,
thank you, I tried to scab her before too I love Nemo She's an idol I really I've talked about Nemo before She was in former She was former member of idol group Nijino Conquistador She's the one that I met at Toho Lost Word Live And she's also an artist And a cute VTuber This This I did see this but i didn't watch it i remember recording this the custom in the custom voice pack oh my gosh if i had known you were going to try and do it for my birthday now i feel so bad so thank you what the heck what the heck i recorded this i recorded this
it's a weird tearing myself
It's awkward.
I'm writing for the Dear Stage.
It's so good.
It's too good.
times i've i've stood in this little parking garage waiting for deer stage or i'll be like let's meet in front of deer stage and i'll be standing here in this little parking garage never give up thank you tuto thank you thank you chest turtle for for the the voice pack oh my gosh i tried although that that speech is kind of hard sorry it sounds so Yeah!
Cute!
There's everything I love in here!
The Maru and Koharu and Snake!
It's everything I love!
Oh, so much stuff!
Oh my gosh!
The Stand-E from Vexpo.
You did get it.
What was I?
I was... No, I was searching for...
What is...
Just gotta scroll up a little bit.
Cute!
What was I gonna say?
Oh, I was looking for the princess thing.
Let's just scroll past that.
Oh!
Lazuli, thank you!
This is so cute!
So, so cute!
Oh, it looks so yummy!
Oh my gosh, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Wait.
Oh.
It's a heart!
Wait, it's a heart!
Sparkler!
Oh my gosh, how is she not getting set on fire?
It's kind of dangerous, no?
It's kind of scary.
Wait, even the tiny hat.
Eat the bag!
Oh, it looks so good.
I love this little chain.
I have it too.
Actually, I think I have most of these things.
Cute cosplay!
That's me!
That's old!
That's before I...
Before my new outfit, my 3.0.
Happy birthday to my girlfriend's wife.
Yeah.
Oh, cute!
Cute Minecraft.
This is so cute!
Ah!
Thank you!
It's okay.
It says...
inflammable I don't know about that I don't know about that cute cute cute cute ah this was I remember doing this this was um same weekend as Sakura Khan yes yes yes wait inflammable inflammable mean the same thing huh really
Sakura Kanikimasu!
If I ever get invited to Sakura Kan, I will say that.
Actually if I get invited to Sakura Kan, I'm gonna ask them if I can recreate that whole commercial.
Sakura Kanikimasu!
As like a, how do I say, announcement video.
Whoa, cute!
Cute!
Oh!
Solem?
He's lifting?
Oh, he's lifting?
4.05.
Is that real?
Holy moly.
Also, last year, too.
What the heck?
Oh, my God.
That's like 20 minutes.
I don't even know.
20.
I weigh zero pounds.
I'm a good.
cute thank you i love you guys have like the stuff from the cafe wait this is awesome it's like all the acrylics from from my mama oh my gosh happy birthday with those oh you're kind of insane you know that wait what is this song
wow this is old
Wow this is old old cover I did this
song for when I For when I Got my 2.0 show Crazy Crazy crazy Gossip thank you for the Waza This is also crazy.
Thanks for accompanying me all these wrestling shows.
Cute!
Cosplay cute!
Yan Art!
Thank you!
Thank
you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Wait, this is so cute too!
Oh my gosh, you guys are...
Cookies!
Oh my gosh!
Wait, this is so cute!
You guys are, everybody's so talented.
Minto Itasha, you!
Look at this look delicious.
With the pen line, it's so cute!
Yeah!
Keep going back, it looks so yummy.
Cute.
Don't do this.
What the hell?
What?
I'll become a rug rat.
It's
like a dead baby.
Thank you.
cute oh my gosh so cute oh she cuts a fit that cute i love this actually wait i love this this this goes hard i would wear this this is so cute what the where is this i need to go here like looking in a mirror don't say that hot dog thank you for spooky Oh,
wait.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Why did everybody commission this guy?
Happy birthday to you.
Oh, oh, no.
happy birthday to you happy birthday dear kitten happy birthday to you i haven't watched this one birthday happy freaking birthday hello princess greetings min phantom because i your alpha daddy no princess no need to be nervous daddy doesn't it makes me so uncomfortable Don't do it again,
please.
You're not going to be this nervous for your birthday, concert.
Put it together, Princess.
You've got this.
Anyway, I'm here today to wish you a very happy birthday, Winnie.
My favorite ghost maid-fiend VTuber.
I'm a big fan.
But it's your birthday.
So, let's get this over again.
Oh my gosh.
Maybe a joke to get us in the news.
There's so much time.
What did...
the horse say when he fell over help I can't give you up to die anyway anyway very happy birthday my princess however you're celebrating whatever it's with friends family why is it so large please have a very happy birthday best of luck with your concert too you're pretty good take care princess oh my god and
there's a second there's another one why did you
know david haters available there's three hold
on i gotta go get some water before david oh no i
have to say something though I saw this one.
Wait, where'd my mouse go?
Oh, here it is.
I saw this one first.
And I'm not gonna lie, I thought it was a face reveal.
But
it was a face reveal.
How
do you thought so too?
Face reveal, what?
And then I did watch this one.
I did watch this one.
Then I watched it and I was like,
I'm crying actual tears okay hold on I'm gonna go get my water VRV I'll be right back gonna get some more water
okay I'm sorry about that I'm back I'm back shall we hopefully that was a sufficient enough of a break so we can watch the next one okay here we go I'm just gonna go for it happy boat two you happy birthday to you the side smile dear kitten on the kitten i was gonna say princess happy birthday to you happy freaking birthday happy freaking boy hello princess greetings mid-fantime it is i your alpha daddy here no no oh princess no need to be nervous
bite it's terrible anyway I'm here today to wish you a very happy birthday and as for your birthday pleasant I got you something special hmm the finest wine I could find for the finest princess I know so tell me careful a drink that is thirsty maybe you me some Metal Gear Solid and some red wine.
Wow what a crazy night.
Anyway a very happy birthday to you but the love does not just come from daddy no oh the wonderful eating my cousin's ass wants to wish you a very happy birthday too.
So however you're celebrating whether it's friends, family, loved ones please make sure it's a wonderful birthday.
Oh thank you.
Literally.
Sit back.
Relax.
up and enjoy your special day take care princess bye-bye why is it so loud wait there's a third one this is so it's actually painful oh my gosh it's actually so so painful to watch
I didn't I did not see a third one.
Oh, this is so cute.
I mean, I'm mixed between Acelot and Snake.
This looks delicious.
I will possess for a bite of the cake.
Thank you.
So cute!
That's me!
Cute, cute.
Wait, we have to listen to this.
You guys, we have to listen to this too.
Because I don't have my...
I don't have...
I don't have V set up.
So let's listen.
Let's listen.
That's me.
Congratulations, happy birthday with salutations.
Happy birthday, may your sky stay blue.
Happy birthday to you.
I like it afterwards when they're just awkwardly standing around like,
Because it just didn't record lines or something.
Yay!
Thank you!
Thank you, all my little men.
Oh yeah, I'm quiet.
That's her thing too.
Yeah, that's me.
That's me.
YouTube's gonna get mad at me.
I don't know what I'm singing here.
But thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh!
Toured into my stream?
Wait, this is kind of insane.
What?
Oh!
Skeletor!
This is so awesome.
You got games on your codec?
Nothing here yet.
Oh, they're gonna add games!
Wow!
Wow, wow, wee!
So cool!
So, so cool!
Oh my gosh!
Wait, this is so stinking cute!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you!
What is this?
Wait.
Sorry, I keep pausing for videos.
Wait, can I play this?
Or am I gonna...
Ah!
2 hot princess Oh what is that?
Oh my god What is this game?
Oh CS2 Oh yeah
let's go Get those kills Nice
I have
to make one next to it with my original song, okay?
Door is stuck?
This is so great.
Wait!
This goes so hard though.
Oh my gosh!
I like how they just like tense up and drop.
It's so funny.
I love just the song too.
Good edit.
Yeah!
It is such a catchy song.
It's so stinking cute.
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
Her fire!
That was awesome.
We have this too.
I'm kind of scared though.
Oh gosh.
Wait.
I'm kind of scared to...
I'm kind of scared to listen to this one though.
Wait!
Two Han points says.
I'm kind of scared.
Let's do fart.
We'll do... 45.
What did I say?
I didn't say fart.
Did I?
That's another thing.
I need to preserve my voice.
Why'd you call me a pervert?
No, I said preserve.
Wait, what did I say?
Aw, man, I want to keep licking.
Not licking.
Pick.
I'm really good at this.
Why is it just...
What do you mean full compilation?
If it's longer, there's more than just a minute.
The full compilation is 16.
What?
Hold on.
No way.
How is it 16 minutes long?
Hold on.
I'm just going to go.
Go into the middle.
It works, you guys.
I literally combined cult.
So I said gult.
Wait.
Because I said government and cult.
Are you like full Mac, full ranked up?
Wait, what?
Full Mac.
What?
Did I say that?
Oh, my bad.
Full Mac.
What?
I never realized it either.
I didn't mess up.
I just went full max.
I just...
No!
I'm holding the pocket watch.
In one hand, he clambers atop the pyre and raises his skull.
Not skulls.
I guess.
No!
Why do I do this so often?
The amount of times you try to deny it.
I feel like I...
Get gaslit!
I don't know...
Raises his skull.
What's this one?
Why are transformers even?
Back attack!
Oh, wait, where's the back shot?
Where's the back?
Oh, never mind!
Okay.
Anyway.
What else?
No!
The let's do fart one kills me.
This one, it kills me though.
Wait, where did I say it?
Wait, what did I say here?
Oh, D for DJ.
That's not me messing up.
I just didn't think about it.
Oh, here.
Is this the Let's Do fart?
Wait, what did I say?
Oh my god.
It's the Polari the Plari.
Not Plari.
It's the Plari the Plata Boys.
It's Plata Boys.
Thank you.
What is this?
Okay.
I blame you for getting this song stuck in my head.
What's the song, though?
Oh, it's this one.
I remember that song.
Ah.
Yay.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh, so cute.
Thank you.
That's me.
Wait, that's Barry.
What the hell?
That's my friend.
Had
to pick between the bundle and the new LEGO's Death Star!
A bit of
taking!
And they're not inviting me!
Where's mine?
Thank you!
This is so cute!
My two favorite!
Hanamaru!
Ow!
Wait, oh my gosh, and it's the Peru Hanamaru, my fan!
this is so cute thank you thank you thank you thank you so cute thank you that's me thank you that's me thank you i like how i'm just like hmm
minky that's me thank you thank you oh so cute
Oh, thank you!
Oh,
that's me.
What?
A bookmark?
Wait, I want to use it.
Cute, thank you!
I will use the whisk-pugging asset.
Thank you, thank you.
Albert art, so pretty.
Thank you.
Thank you, so cute!
What shirt am I wearing?
Hell.
What a batch of...
Oh, music.
A brookie suffice.
What's a brookie?
Oh my gosh, me hugging Ocelot.
Just got home from a business trip.
Oh,
it's me!
Oh, this is a Kiwawa.
This is during Kiwawa's.
Yeah.
Thank you, thank you, everybody.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Friends!
Oh, my friend!
Oh, even...
Actually, Maple drew the, um...
The wisps for, uh, the concert.
So...
Mmm.
A brookie is a cookie combined with a brownie.
Oh, wait, that sounds awesome.
I would like that, yes.
Yeah.
So, I'm having them there too!
And my boys in my lap.
This is like everything I love in one photo.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Wow, this cake looks insane!
Holy moly!
Thank you so much!
Oh my gosh, and you got the Lego!
Not Lego, mythical brick.
Thank you, thank you.
That's me.
Old me.
Me!
Oh,
listen?
Happy birthday people!
Thank
you so much!
I saw you guys were doing this, oh my god!
Thank you!
So wholesome, yeah.
Well, the people who got together.
Thank you.
So cute, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
There's so many posts.
Oh, that's my butt.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Whoa, this box.
Wait, the new box looks insane.
Holy cow.
Ah!
Good!
I will spare listening on stream.
Thank you!
What the heck?
I still have my other box.
The original box.
Thank you so much!
Oh my god!
Whoa!
Remix!
I want to hear it.
Oh!
Oh, there we go.
We're fine.
I want to hear.
Adjust your volume.
I am.
Oh, my gosh.
It's long even.
Faster.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
I will try and use it in the future.
Thank you!
Wow, this looks so yummy!
Oh, thank you, thank you!
Oh, this is me.
We reached the top.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, everybody!
Thanks to everybody who got the bundle!
Thank you for posting the screenshots and everything!
Really, really appreciate it.
Don't look at my skirt.
Thank you!
I'm out and busy, but I feel like the hard-making- AHHHHH!
Maple!
Thank you!
Thanks for everybody for getting the bundle!
Oh my gosh, thanks for the cat!
Look at him!
Ah, thank you!
What the hell?
What the heck, Murphy?
for ordering thank you thank you thank you thank you oh gosh seeing the prices i i'm trying i don't want to look oh my god i'm so sorry about how much shipping is for some of you guys fortunately i do not control any of that so no thank you thank you thank you i'm sold out
Wait, I'm sold out?
Oh!
Holy cow!
The bundle sold out!
Well!
Oh my gosh, thank you!
Oh my god, thank you guys!
But the- everything else- Everything else will stay up until the end of the month, so...
Um...
Even though they were so much?
Everything else will stay up until the end of the month.
So, um, if you, uh, even if you couldn't get the bundle, you can still get everything.
Everything will be up.
It's made to order.
So, you can get that all still until the end of the month.
Yes.
But thank you!
Oh my gosh, I didn't think actually it would sell out though.
I didn't think it would sell out.
Because it was so expensive.
40 hours editing, oh my gosh!
Thank you!
I already have the slippers.
Shut up!
Oh, wait, I was...
There we go, I accidentally scrolled.
Thank you so cute!
Thank you everybody for ordering!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you.
You're pretty good.
Come by.
Crazy.
You cooked with the merch choices.
Thank you.
What's your cut from merch?
50-50!
Cut is good.
Yeah, so.
So, if you are at, if you purchase, you are very much, um, very much supporting.
So, so don't worry.
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah.
So, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Wow, I can't believe all the bundles sold out
I have you
Um But yeah, thank you so much you guys I hope you enjoyed the concert yesterday And Um, you know Uh I I wanted it to be you know the best it could be since you guys always give me the best that I can have so I hopefully will be able to do many more projects in the future you know it's a little tougher since I'm since I'm indie a lot more cost involved so probably things won't be as frequent as you know other others but I will do have more stuff in the future and and yeah I really really appreciate it I will
try and try and do as much as I can for you guys because you guys let me do so much and it
was it's not gonna lie it's been a kind of a crappy year but I'm I'm glad that I can still you know celebrate today I'm glad that I still have something to celebrate so so
and I stress so much about the or two.
So I'm glad I ended up being good and I'm glad that I could end up having merch for you guys too and
I hope that I hope that I hope that from here on out it's well there's I hope all the tough stuff is behind us and from here on out It can be much, much more fun times instead.
Now we're past all this silly stuff.
And we'll just keep moving forward.
And I'll keep working harder.
And there is actually some very cool stuff planned in the future.
So, actually...
Yeah, actually, I do have stuff not announced yet, too, so many, many cool things coming up.
So, you can look forward to that, too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's all coming up, Mickey, from here.
So, there's still more cool stuff around the corner.
And, you know, I got more cons.
coming up.
I have the Idol Festival at the end of this month, and I have Holiday Matsuri in December and even other things.
Um, what?
Some things will are happening, but won't be until later.
Yeah,
Club Iron Mouse too!
Yes, yes, yes, thank you.
Yes, yes, yes.
That was announced recently as well.
Caught the 3D debut by this morning.
Thank you!
Yeah, Hollow Hunger.
I thought it was kind of spooky.
Happy birthday, Mickey.
Thank you!
Thank you so much, you guys.
It's mean we can have 3D streams now.
I have a couple things that I'm trying to get what's the word?
Ironed out with my 3D model.
but once that is the case then yeah 3d streams yeah yeah sorted out a couple things so but but yeah there's there's actually there's some really cool stuff but some stuff i think it's cool i think it's cool hopefully you guys think it's cool too so some of it one thing It's like,
if it happens, it's like, it's like bragging rights.
So, it's kind of crazy that I still am offered some of these things as, even as an indie.
I feel really, really, really lucky.
Even if this year has been unlucky.
It's been unlucky and lucky at the same time.
You know, I don't want to just always be...
You know, the...
The B-Shoujo thing was, you know, a pretty big loss on my end, you know.
There was some really big things that all fell through.
Luckily, the concert still made it through, but...
There was one other thing that fell through that I was...
really really excited for but at the same time I've also been able to do so much and we'll keep and I keep being able to do so much so I don't want to just be thinking about that all the time and I don't I don't even if you don't think I do you might be like oh she's coping no no I I also,
I try to move on and, you know, if I stay too much on the past, then I would just be so sad all the time.
So, I don't want to be sad.
I want to be, I want to be, I want to be someone that you can watch and be like, wow, she's so goofy.
happy after hard day work so you know that's what that's always my number one goal for you guys is to is to have a fun time hmm yes yes I do I do all the sad stuff behind the scenes so that you guys can have fun on the street but fun times ahead i'm i'm hopeful for i'm hopeful for the future so thank you guys i'm gonna call it here today's stream was fun it made me happy even though it was just me yapping sorry i didn't have so much plan for today but I think the concert yesterday was a lot,
so...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you guys, thank you.
Thank you!
Proud of you putting together such an incredible 3D debut, despite more than your share of setbacks this year.
I'm sorry that I'm a little...
bit of unlucky.
If you...
If I'm your Oshi, I'm sorry.
If...
You picked such an unlucky Oshi.
My luck is very strange.
It swings in such directions, I think.
I'm either zero luck or a hundred luck, maybe.
It's very dramatic.
And never in between.
You're awesome.
Never let anyone say otherwise.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Come on!
But...
Um...
But I feel...
I feel the most lucky.
Even if I'm unlucky sometimes, I still feel the most lucky ever in the world, so...
Yeah.
And I won't go to Vegas.
Thank you so, so, so much.
Thank you.
Uh...
Hmm...
You're pretty good.
Maybe New Vegas?
New Vegas.
What's New Vegas?
I can make my own Vegas.
Okay, you guys, I'm going to make my own Vegas with blackjack and hookers.
And then it'll be called New Vegas.
Oh, wait, that's Fallout.
Okay,
hold on.
It will be called.
This stole my idea.
How is that different from current Vegas?
Because I own a
house always wins.
Pinky always wins.
Yeah.
We'll call it Las Vegas 2.
Las Vegas 2, New Vegas.
Two Las 2 Vegas.
Outer Vegas.
Wait, can my Vegas also have the giant sphere that nobody likes?
Can I also?
Can I also do that?
Can you talk us through your creative process for the ghost-made Kyusha mix?
A few words, oomps, that are still trying to decipher.
Ah!
Um, honestly, the lyrics were entirely Panda Boy.
And they were so perfect that...
I told them that I did want, like, a mix that I wanted World Chaos in it.
And...
He did it.
And then he was kind of just like...
What...
What kind of things do you like?
And I was like...
Metal Gear?
I'm like... I'm a ghost maid.
Even though you're pretty good?
Yeah, that was him!
Everything was him!
He kind of...
It was him!
It was all him!
um hold on the where are my lyrics
i can try and help you out but i also said that qqsa is my favorite japanese word so qqsa mix
and i love the i love the So just, I love it.
The whole thing is so good.
I really love the song.
It's a lot of fun to me.
And fun to sing.
And yeah.
I'll have to find it.
Where is it?
If I don't find it tonight, I will post later.
my brain is too mush for everything right now i can't remember a single dang thing oh wait is it in here
i can't even i can't even read i can't even read it's the smoothest my brain has been in a long time so sorry so sorry Wait, what is this?
I'm looking through my Google Drive right now.
Here you guys, I'll give you this today.
This is, whoa, I found this.
Wow, I found a bunch of old stuff.
Here you guys go.
For my birthday, I grant you This.
Good for one tuck into bed and one kiss on the forehead.
That's you lying in bed.
Looking so happy, ready to be tucked into bed.
There you go.
Look at, you can even tell how old it is because it's 1.0 me.
It's not even so good.
This is...
Um...
Yeah.
Never mind, don't redeem that.
I forgot to fix it, the picture.
Do not redeem!
It's supposed to- I know what it's supposed to be, you guys.
It's supposed to be...
Like the blankets.
Like the ruffled of the blanket.
But I remember!
I remember this happened literally five years ago.
Yeah, like the blanket po- I posted it with very wholesome intentions and everyone had this.
The same reaction.
And I forgot.
I'm never doing anything for you guys ever again.
Okay, I'm gonna go.
Thank you, everybody, for a birthday.
Thank you for my birth!
I have this coupon.
It is, it is, I should put expires.
It doesn't have an expiration date, does it?
It doesn't.
Oh my god.
It's supposed to be a fold in the blanket.
Wait, I can fix this.
I can fix it right now!
Okay, revised version.
please use this version instead the other version will get you banned the other version will get you banned from the internet so please here good for one tuck into bed and one kiss on the forehead and that's me saying
I can't believe it Oh, okay.
I'm gonna go then.
Otsu, Minto, everybody.
Thank you so much for celebrating my birthday with me yesterday and today.
Thank you for selling out the bundles.
The merch will be available until the end of the month.
Yeah.
I'm very, very grateful for all your support.
I'll keep working hard as I do.
And I will...
Yeah!
Thank you everybody, thank you, thank you, thank you!
I will see you guys tomorrow or whenever I see you next.
Have a good day, have a good night, have a good time zone.
I love you all very, very much.
for
all the birthday wishes thank you so much bye bye bye